coming to you from Atop The Channel 8
helipad playing the game pickleball okay
if you haven't been paying attention
pickleball has become the rage across
the country it is a great game for
families and a lot of people are picking
up I have friends who are going crazy
over this I have a sister in law who's
big into it and here we have the
Reynolds Family they are into this
specifically because Dad miles Reynolds
is the owner of Las Vegas sport court
how you doing good how are you and this
is you have a beautiful family by the
way thank you and this is something they
really enjoy obviously oh they love it I
mean my daughter blakely's always like
Dad when we gonna play Pickleball and
even my seven-year-old son cruises like
that sign me up for seven-year-old
pickleball and I'm like I don't know do
they have that yeah now they do actually
so yeah it has it's just grown so much
yeah it's exploding and you were
actually setting up courts in people's
backyards now correct so we've we've
been doing sports construction here in
Las Vegas for 17 years and pickleball's
been the fastest growing sport for five
years now so every new community and
every backyard court is pickleball so
this is a makeshift Court of course yeah
and we don't want to hit too far because
it's over the edge well this is the
first that we've done that we're doing
on a helicopter path yeah so uh yeah
well there yeah there's one but you'll
let that ball go we'll get it later yeah
so but yes it's just uh and then you
know even my dad he's uh in his late 70s
even he comes into town well that's the
thing this is a low impact sport for the
most part so it it you can have a range
of athletic abilities playing this game
correct yeah so it's
um yeah so one thing that we're super
excited about is you know it's exclusive
news for us is uh USA pickleball is a
national governing body for the sport of
pickleball and uh Sport Court actually
just became the official modular tile
surface uh partner of USA pickleball
which basically just means a lot of
people play on acrylic just a painted
concrete cord right yeah well it's great
for the pros that are 20 but when you
know for me my doctor's already telling
me like you have the knees of a 7 an
year old already like my orthopedic
doctor so when you want to have safety
when you want to play longer when you
want to have less injury like my kids we
have a court in our backyard if my kids
are falling down or skidding out last
night yeah I mean concrete has zero head
impact right so safety is more that's
really the driving force for this new
Surface is safety and a lot of you know
older people want it for their joints to
play longer but then parents want it for
their kids if they're going to Skid out
yeah there's a little sponginess to it
right they don't want to crash and burn
yes there's some some head impact and
it's low abrasion this is going on all
over the place is it affordable for most
families to put this in their backyard
yeah you know it really it comes down to
two different things if you have the
space right and then also it you know it
does take a budget to put it in how much
space would you need on average it's
about a 30 by 60 so that's by far most
popular our most popular size quartz and
some people have lights with theirs in
the whole area so so for us I mean
there's definitely cheaper ways to build
a court sometimes people are like hey
I'm just gonna have a slab of concrete
in the net yeah we usually get involved
people care about I want it to want it
to be safe I want it to look beautiful I
wanted to have the wow factor I wanted
to have lights logos fencing that's
really when we get involved is to really
customize it tell people where they can
find you online so we do so we do have a
podcast pickleball Builders okay and
then also our website is
supportcourtlasvegas.com but we come out
and just you know kind of take a look at
the overall area and see if it's a if
it's an option or not but I will say I
mean it's just it's sweeping the country
it is it's absolutely I mean it's like
it's exploding at the seams well miles
Reynolds and the Reynolds Family great
job today really appreciate you being
here